treize communes ont signé la charte
ville amie des enfants dans les yvelines
dans l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines elles sont trois directions
guyancourt ce jour là les membres du
conseil municipal des enfants
participent à un atelier sur le
harcèlement scolaire avec les policiers
dans le cadre du label ville amie des
enfants il ya une des thématiques qui
est la participation des enfants et des
jeunes de la ville et le conseil
municipal des enfants c'est ça les
enfants viennent pour mettre en place
des projets pour les enfants de la ville
parmi ces projets la création d'un jeu
c'est un jeu de société pour
sensibiliser sur tous les enfants et les
adolescents au harcèlement la ville de
guyancourt est l'une des premières de
l'agglomération à être entré dans ce
réseau ville amie des enfants en 2006 ce
réseau permet effectivement un certain
nombre de mutualisation de bonnes
pratiques au travers de temps des
changes de temps de mutualisation mais
aussi de rencontres annuelles
le principe est donc de mettre en place
des politiques publiques favorables à la
jeunesse c'est de promouvoir la
déclaration internationale des droits de
l'enfant à montigny le bretonneux les
centres périscolaires sont justement en
pleine préparation d'une journée
spéciale pour les 30 ans de la
déclaration le 20 novembre
ou est en train de faire un clip pour la
chanson dont ledroit la chanson ça parle
des droits de l'enfant comme droit
d'être protégé des sauniers d'avoir une
nationalité le droit de bien manger
d'être le j'ai éduqué réalisation d'un
clip vidéo mais aussi d'une fresque avec
le logo de l'unicef
c'est important de fêter les 30 ans de
la convention internationale avec les
enfants qui soit pareil qui soit
participatif sur cette journée montigny
le bretonneux fait partie du réseau
villes amies des enfants depuis 2012 n'a
toujours fait beaucoup puisque c'était
quand on a eu baby boom dans les années
80 il fallait ouvrir des écoles
construire des crèches investir des
enfants au coeur du fonctionnement de la
ville au travers d'un conseil municipal
dédié pour eux organiser des activités
ludiques et éducatives sur les temps
périscolaires
autant d'éléments pour entrer dans le
réseau ville amie des enfants un accord
avec l'unicef qui se renouvelle à chaque
mandat municipal